how do you balance it's hard I get it
like bouncing a career family everything
going on how do you do that well you
know Fame is tricky if Fame could be a
very tricky thing as you know as you
guys can imagine and we've experienced
and it could be very intoxicating to
people and I also feel like with Fame
I felt early that it was really
important to keep perspective and to
understand that really Fame is like a
microscope and it magnifies who you are
as a human being and what you have in
your DNA and it's all true colors your
true colors sure and I think what's
helped me and certainly my family is
just just remembering where I've come
from and keeping the hard times that
I've went through in the past now the
forefront of my mind helped lead and
guide me that way if we're fortunate
enough to have any bit of success
whatever it is come our way you take it
with a grain of salt you're super
grateful that it happens but it's not
everything it's not everything no not at
all and just like that things can change
so be super grateful and try and live in
gratitude every day and yes because
somebody told me yeah because I try and
live like that my biggest fear in this
industry I've never said this in an
interview anywhere but I don't know why
I'm saying it now your your you should
be a [ __ ]
no my biggest fear is becoming those
people you meet that are so unhappy in
this industry and I'm like what went
wrong wait you used to be really lovely
I knew you and way back when and it's
like what went wrong and that's the
thing I think you just lose sight of it
you chase and you chase me a chase and
you don't enjoy enjoy enjoy you know
absolutely you know and I always think
like I get asked this question often I'm
sure you do too like don't you miss like
the anonymity of just being able to go
them all or just being able to go out
and I say because that just doesn't
happen anymore for me and I say I have
put on bucket hats but I also you know I
remind myself well what's the
alternative the alternative could be I
go back to how things were when I had
seven bucks in my pocket and that was it
or getting it Vicky I remember that
running from the repo man I did
my car my friends apartment I was like
shoot I don't know my car I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this